this week I took part in the climate
strike in Bristol joining around 30,000
others in the rain on college green I
traveled back from London to take part
in the strike because Bristol is my
hometown and because this is a seriously
important moment for the climate
movement in the UK and the reason for
that is because of this girl greater Tim
Berg
she has brought hundreds of thousands of
people together to protest the lack of
action from governments on climate
change starting from a one-person
protest she found herself this week
leading a march of tens of thousands
through the city of Bristol as someone
with relevant scientific training I
totally understand the criticisms of
grete Tim Berg and her role in the
climate movement I've hesitated to make
public comment on her in the past
precisely because of these complaints
wouldn't it be better to use a scientist
as a figurehead isn't the movement
rather cult-like does greater actually
understand the science or if she's just
parroting lines from a school textbook
but as I stood maybe 50 metres from this
girl who was greeted with deafening
roars to the stage I was struck almost
immediately by a few things when
speaking she had an undeniable presence
it wasn't showy it wasn't even really
charismatic but it was entrancing I
immediately understood why so many
people have followed her in the climate
strike movement her speech was delivered
calmly quietly and simply it was a
climate message stripped down to its
bare essentials the problem with talking
about climate change is that it is a
complicated topic when scientists speak
to the public or to government on the
issue we tend to get more focused on the
trees and less on the forests more about
the details and less about the big
picture
we give uncertainties and caveats and
alternative explanations and those
things are not compelling to government
ministers or tea up average voter
they obfuscate the message you're trying
to get across these people don't have
scientific training they need an
abstract not a full review paper and the
thing is for quite some time now the
science has been settled there's
obviously window dressing to be done and
lots of uncertainties still to be nailed
down the review
paper is far from finished but the
abstract conclusion is human activity
has warmed the planet with unprecedented
speed and will do so at an increasing
rate if we don't change our activities
soon and that warming will affect
everyone not just scientists it will
affect everyday people from all walks of
life and from every country around the
world we are all stakeholders in our
collective response to human-made
climate change so with that in mind does
it matter that the figurehead of this
movement is a teenage girl who hasn't
read all the scientific papers no she's
a teenage girl who was repeating the
abstract conclusions of tens of
thousands of scientists and outright
telling governments to listen to those
scientists she's not an authority and
recognizes that but she will be affected
by climate change in her lifetime and so
has just as much a right to be heard on
this issue as the scientists but she is
not and she herself is at pains to
stress that she is not the beginning and
end of this movement it extends beyond
her to the scientific community to the
voting population she is just a spark
the people at the March with a flame and
the flame is what's important a spark
will not force governments to take
meaningful action whether that spark is
a climate scientist or a teenager a
flame however cannot be ignored and
Greta's spark lit tinder around the
world the simplicity of her message the
calm she exudes roused people to action
in a way that climate scientists have
not those people at the March were
inspired by her and she was inspired by
the scientists she listened to this
movement this March was based on science
it just took the simplicity of greta's
message to get people to listen the
March itself was uniquely Bristolian I
was really proud to come from the West
country seeing all the unique and funny
and creative ways that people were
contributing to this movement not least
the fact that even horrible weather
didn't put a dampener on the event
although we did slightly turned collard
green into college mud sorry Bristol
City Council the councillor for striking
for climate
trying to retake the fortress of Verdun
Bristol has long been at the forefront
of demanding action on climate change in
the UK and this March will have only
strengthened the momentum of this
movement in the city further just last
week Bristol Airport was denied
permission to build a new runway after
extensive lobbying by this movement and
a couple of days ago London Heathrow was
denied the same expansion after judges
ruled that the UK must uphold its
commitments to the Paris agreement and
with tens of thousands of people taking
to the streets and many many more
cheering from their offices and from
scaffolding it really felt like change
is coming and the Bristol was going to
be at the forefront in studying and
covering climate change it's easy to
feel a sense of hopelessness and it's
important to realize that the situation
we find ourselves in is pretty dire we
face a difficult century full of tough
choices but it's not hopeless one of my
favorite quotes comes from Desmond Tutu
the Archbishop of Capetown during the
time when the system of apartheid in
South Africa was first broken down I
would hope I mean that the world would
realize that there is no situation that
is not transferrable
that there is no situation of which we
can say this is absolutely totally
devoid of hope
of course that is work people thought
about South Africa this March showed me
that there is a clear demand for action
and that the demand is growing louder
and louder and producing results these
results show that there is hope we don't
have to resign ourselves to the worst
case scenario and all of this is only
possible because of the following of a
single girl whose demand is just that
the public listens to the science
arguably this teenager from Sweden has
produced a more meaningful change in the
public's demands from their governments
than decades of scientists lobbying
those same governments would I rather
that the public and the government's
paid Heat those scientists warnings
directly and could access and understand
the scientific papers on the subject
absolutely yes but if greater timbo can
produce this momentum this spark by
simply and repeatedly making the same
points then that works by me let's hope
that this particular flame burns on and
burns brighter because we all need it to
thanks for watching I'll see you in the
next one